it's the cuomo's
whoa
starring andrew
and chris
cool
yeah
one's a perv and the other's got a lot
of nerve
cause he brought down zuck and now he
wants 60 million bucks
welcome to a brand new season of it's
the cuomo's i'm your host sandy duncan
i cannot believe that we got a second
season
tonight's episode from grabbing ass to
grabbing cash following jeff zucker's
cnn exit disgraced anchor chris tends to
demand as much as a 60 million dollar
settlement almost a million bucks for
each one of his viewers but it's a
bargain for helping to destroy cnn's
credibility that number is according to
the new york post which is owned by our
parent company tom cruise
apparently chris who was canned in
december for helping his brother andrew
fend off sexual harassment allegations
instead of helping women fend off his
brother it will claim that zucker not
only knew about it but that zucker had
inappropriate dealings with andrew as
well said one source quote chris intends
to fight for every dollar on his
contract and loss of income from the 15
to 20 years left in his career
yeah had zucker not orchestrated a f job
on him
i won't spell that out emily because
you're here
meanwhile
cnn reports the older cuomo is
considering a political comeback if he
gets one nursing home vote though i'm
alleging fraud
after resigning last summer following
sexual harassment allegations andrew
avoided impeachment which means he's
still eligible to run for office again
now this isn't new he's just following
the footsteps of other disgraced horny
democrats like elliot spitzer and
anthony weiner who both tried to run for
office once the courts removed their
ankle monitors
for more on this we go live to larry
cuomo
yes the other cuomo and some say the
smartest but forgotten brother
leave me out of this i'm normal
[Laughter]
it's probably that's why he's the
smartest cuomo joe he stays out of this
mess i think that was that was shemp
cuomo yeah it was simple
i couldn't get chem but i got larry and
moe you know he's passed on what do you
think joe uh do you think that he has a
chance in a comeback and is chris cuomo
really
is his career ruined or is he just
saying that he he said he's got that
extra 80 years in the business that he
got ripped
two weeks ago i was riding the subway i
don't mean to brag
and i saw a woman wearing a homosexual
t-shirt
and i thought when's the last time she
did laundry yes because it's time to
retire that and then they're back
they're back again who's going to be
avenetti is going to be back we're going
to bring him from jail and run the two
of them for president that would be
fantastic it's it's amazing i mean i
think it's funny that of all the people
to bring down cnn it's chris cuomo yeah
that's hilarious his brother running for
office again is frightening i mean he
killed more old people than if he
poisoned the early bird special but i
guess we're going to let that slide
that's a thing that no one talks about
by the way i got to bring this up to you
because tyrus this is so great
i love how don lemon who you know these
they used to do that talk love affair
and now he's mad he's saying that you
know giving cuomo money integrity yeah
yeah wait don't give cuomo money because
it will show that lack of journalistic
integrity is a payoff
looks like people are awful looks like
no more beautiful dinners in the city
greg
looks like that's over uh you know what
i
i side with chris cuomo i think he's
he's right i think he you know i don't
know about all the money thing but
100 percent tucker knew what was going
on and he was doing it because he was
doing the same thing with trump mm-hmm
so yeah and he thought he was going to
jump from trump
to the uh to his big brother and he was
going to ride that to the white house
right so everything that he did he was
getting advice from 100 yeah so i do
feel from that as far as being disgraced
i don't think so much it's what
happening at cnn but probably the sexual
harassment thing you know that zucker is
not responsible for that yeah yeah so i
think he's got to deal with that one but
uh he's going to get some money yeah
what do you what you know cat when you
look at uh chris cuomo what what would
he spend the 60 million dollars on
what do you think
i don't know
the
protein shakes like glamour shots i told
i i really thought he was going to start
and only fans that was my
oh
that's what he wants to do yes he's a
flexer that's what he oh i'm
accidentally naked in the background of
the photo like or the video like he
should just do that i don't it's crazy
because now you know for a fact that
they're both actually narcissists
because they think he's you know andrew
still thinks he
should he's entitled to have power over
tens of millions of people and chris
thinks he's entitled to tens of millions
of dollars even though like they have
both screwed up so much that it's like
hard to keep all of them straight
without forgetting something i know i
know and i think you should get a gold
and diamond
big block necklace that says let's get
after it and just wear it and just go
walk around why you got to give him my
culture stuff
[Laughter]
hell no
but i just want to see him shirtless
wearing it in the hamptons hopping onto
an uh helicopter
a solid gold helicopter
i mean whatever that whatever that is
worth it's not worth 60 million dollars
yes these guys are just like the the
brother herpes right right when you
think it's gone away they just show up
again like a disgusting sore or wart and
my favorite part about andrew trying to
make a comeback by the way is that he's
such a petulant child about it right
because we had the aeg coming out that
is like nothing nothing takes away the
fact that multiple investigations
concluded credibly that you are a serial
harasser and an abuser and a lot worse
and he's like well um i didn't resign
because i said i did something bad i
just said because i was a distraction
like i left the door open right he's
like the bitmoji where it's in front of
the mirror like today is going to be a
great day i can do it but you know what
the more i thought about it the more i
realized that um that would be a gift
that would be a gift to new york
politics because all it's going to be is
a civil war between the democrat party
because right now no one's defending him
but no one's also saying that he's a
disgusting waste of flesh and so let
them eat each other when it gets to the
primaries because if it gets all the way
the gop candidate is going to win all
right you know uh you stumbled into a
good point
but but let's be honest i know this uh
no the rest of america doesn't care
about this but he is still better than
the current governor kathy hokel or ho
chill is
they managed to find somebody less
appealing than andrew cuomo she's like
your crazy aunt right isn't she i don't
know anyway
i mean
like he's he's an abuse he's a harasser
yeah he's a harasser yeah like confirmed
yeah exactly no like i i mean i don't
know him i'd just bring a big magnet and
his nipple rings would rip right off
there you go
he needs to get maced and nobody is
naked and drinks coffee nobody everybody
risks that yeah
all right
i'm sorry to say shut up to you by the
way
that's a burn that doesn't go away oh
that's true that's true i learned that
at mcdonald's
[Laughter]
no pants i didn't press charges because
i was in such pain up next anti-cop
policies bring no relief and a crook who
snatched all the beef hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else